bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue pour cette dernière émission de la
semaine on est ravis de vous accueillir
pour débattre de quatre sujets qu'on va
découvrir tout de suite en images le
premier ministre était hier l'invité de
l'émission politique sur france 2 avec
un face à face assez tendu face à
laurent wauquiez le patron des
républicains
les thèmes l'immigration l'europe qui a
été le plus convaincant vous le
deviendrez votre point de vue les
agressions contre les policiers se
multiplient ces dernières semaines
hier c'est le patron de la police
municipale de rodez qui a été assassiné
les réponses des pouvoirs publics et du
gouvernement sont-elles à la hauteur où
monsieur collomb est il aux abonnés
absents là encore on se posera la
question et puis on parlera des ours
le ministre de l'écologie veut
réintroduire de nouveaux ours dans les
pyrénées
les bergers sont violemment contre
accusant ces charmantes bestioles de
tuer leurs brebis et vous êtes-vous ours
aux bergers et puis on parlera d'un
sujet ambitieux pour terminer cette
semaine on va prendre de la hauteur le
libéralisme détruites ils les classes
moyennes c'est la thèse du dernier livre
du géographe christophe guilluy et nous
en parlerons avec nos quatre invités
bonsoir olivier babeau pourquoi vous
êtes économiste président fondateur de
l'institut sapiens est un think tank eu
deux annonces libéral et vous êtes
l'auteur d'un d'un éloge un déluge ou
une éloge d un des loges merci de
l'hypocrisie
ça a été publié aux éditions du cerf
partager le même éditeur avec votre
voisin arnaud benedetti bonsoir pourquoi
vous êtes professeur associé à la
sorbonne est votre dernier livre le coup
de com permanents a été est également
publiée dans cette excellente maison
qu'est le serbe ont soif g kuzmanovic
bonsoir vous êtes secrétaire national du
parti de gauche et orateur nationale de
la france insoumise et étienne girard
est là aussi bon soir etienne bonsoir
vous êtes journaliste politique à
l'hebdomadaire marianne
marianne qui publie cette semaine un
dossier sur les flics les profs les
chauffeurs les urgentistes tous ceux qui
s'en prennent plein la gueule
on commence cette émission avec de la
politique je le disais le premier
ministre était hier sur france 2 pour
l'émission politique il ya eu un moment
attendu le tête à tête ou le face à face
avec laurent wauquiez le patron des
républicains
c'était chaud assez chaud même regardez
cet extrait j'étais il ya quelques
semaines à rillieux-la-pape une commune
qui est au nord de lyon où il ya
beaucoup de familles originaires de
l'immigration et une mère de famille est
venue me voir en me disant mais monsieur
wauquiez
ça peut pas marcher parce que dans la
classe de ma fille il ya une personne
sur deux qui aujourd'hui ne parle plus
le français à la maison et donc elle n'a
aucune chance d'y arriver est de s'en
sortir
ce que cette mère de famille a le
courage de dire vous n'avez pas le
courage vous sur ce plateau de répondre
clairement
est ce que vous considérez oui ou non de
wauquiez que le niveau d'immigration est
beaucoup trop élevé alors il ya comme ça
des échanges donc assez tendue sur
l'immigration sur l'europe on vous pose
la question sur twitter chers
internautes selon vous qui a été le plus
convaincant dans ce débat de l'émission
politique pour l'instant vous êtes 55 %
à considérer que c'est le premier
ministre edouard philippe
et vous étiez jira non pas
particulièrement j'ai trouvé le premier
ministre particulièrement sur la
défensive il était acculé de questions
précises et perfide par par laurent
wauquiez
il a eu beaucoup de mal à se dégager
pourquoi citer perfide les questions
parce que laurent wauquiez voulait le
coincer sur les sur l'immigration en le
poussant à à ceux à se dévoiler sur
skull qu'il pensait de la politique
d'immigration en france
donc voilà il y avait à voir nathan du
politique derrière des arts lesquels les
questions de laurent wauquiez
edouard philippe ne s'est jamais n'est
jamais rentré dans le jeu de laurent
wauquiez mais en même temps il a eu
beaucoup de mal à
à exposer un discours clair sur la
question
c'est vrai que ça a paru assez confus il
a expliqué que en effet le niveau
d'immigration légale était étiez au plus
haut que c'était pas que c'était pas
pour autant un appel d'air mais sans
dire exactement ce que c'était donc s'il
fallait donner un gagnant ce serait
peut-être peut-être laurent wauquiez
mais s'ils étaient ils avaient le beau
rôle si je puis dire puisqu'il était pas
d'un rôle du premier opposant alors manu
sur twitter est plutôt d'accord avec
vous puisqu'il considère que le premier
ministre n'avait pas de réponse
il répondait un peu systématiquement que
tout est complexe sans proposer beaucoup
de choses concrètes sur la problématique
migratoire djandji kuzmanovic ces deux
sujets qui ont fait l'objet du débat
d'hier c'est-à-dire l'immigration à
l'europe
bon c'est assez chaud aussi à la france
insoumise vous avez des débats entre
vous vous vous êtes plutôt sur la ligne
wauquiez ou la ligne philippe mais sur
aucun des deux je trouve ça en fait je
suis assez choqué par ce genre de débat
où on les présente comme des opposants à
l'un à l'autre il y à peine un peu plus
d'un an et c'était dans même parti et ce
sont des gens qui défendent strictement
la lie la même ligne politique en termes
d'économies d'ailleurs je suis très
d'accord sur le sujet mais c'est
intéressant quand il faut bien singer
une distinction quelque part mais là
vous pouvez maintenant il ya pas de
différence entre les deux non mais c'est
intéressant parce que wauquiez parle de
l'école qui quand il était ministre sous
la présidence sarkozy à contribuer à
détruire en ne finançant pas et en
appliquant comme le fait philippe les
mêmes les mêmes règles imposées par
l'union européenne ultralibérale et donc
on est on est et puis c'est aussi celui
qui a inspiré d'une certaine manière
macron puisque il était contrôlé minima
sociaux l'autre parle pognon de dengue
et donner aux pauvres gens
les deux sont pour distribuer le plus
riche vous revenez vite sociale quand
même et non mais parce que toutes les
social en fait mais tout est social
juste et c'est pas son opposant c'est ça
que je voulais souligner et on essaie de
construire des oppositions fictives
alors c'est vrai que sur lui a
maintenant besoin de se démarquer de
philippe donc il a choisi le thème de
l'immigration pour pourra-t-il boisé
sedrati boisé des électeurs chez marine
le pen
l'autre a l'air un peu gêné aux
entournures sur cette question mais en
même temps il est celui qui a appliqué
une loi asile et migrations qui est
quand même assez assez radical y compris
sur l'internement des enfants ce qui ce
que son président critique quand il
parle de trumpf a avancé assez confus
tout ça oui en fait peut-être qu on a du
mal à me benedetti à situe vraiment les
positions parce que le renvoi qui
reproche au premier ministre par exemple
d'accueillir des migrants et en même
temps on entend le gouvernement qui dit
nous n'accueillons pas de migrants et
derrière les français sont plutôt
d'accord puisque dans un sondage doxa
pour le figaro les trois quarts des
sondés disent que ils soutiennent cette
position donc en fait on a du mal à voir
en tout il y en a pas un qui est bros
immigration et l'autre qui est anti oui
alors d'abord moi ce qui m'a frappé
quand même c'est l'extrême tension qui
mailly se manifester dans ce débat on
voyait clairement et sans que cela soit
fin qu'il y avait une réelle inimitiés
entre les deux hommes et ça c'est
quelque chose qui est apparue de manière
assez visible pour le téléspectateur
donc au delà des divergences politiques
il y avait de ce point de vue là une
vraie rivalité alors ensuite sur le plan
politique
en effet mais la difficulté c'est que
l'un comme l'autre finalement s'adresser
aux mêmes coeur électorale et la
stratégie de wauquiez c'est une
stratégie qui aujourd'hui vise à couper
la route à droite ou maquereau nhien et
au maquereau nist donc évidemment sur la
question de l'immigration il sait qu'il
faut avoir un discours qui soit un
discours d'une certaine manière
suffisamment compréhensibles
suffisamment lisible pour le coeur de
cet électorat donc sa communication de
ce point de vue là elle était beaucoup
plus audible que celle du premier
ministre qui manifestement avait une
communication sur ce sujet qui visait
quand même malgré tout à rassurer son
aile gauche tout en donnant des gages à
l'électorat conservateur et on voit bien
que finalement il exprimé une position
politique sur un sujet qui est
extrêmement clivant qui est le sujet la
problématique migratoire ou finalement
la stratégie de communication du en même
temps touche très rapidement à ses
limites parce que finalement sur un
sujet où on demande finalement des
positions claires voire parfois binaire
est certainement très souvent manichéen
elle et c'est celui qui communiquera de
la manière la plus explicite et la plus
claire sur le sujet qui à un moment
donné sera le mieux entendu et de ce
point de vue là je suis assez d'accord
avec ce que vous dites je trouvais j'ai
trouvé que wauquiez en tout cas sur le
plan de la performance de la
communication avait été beaucoup plus
cohérent dans son expression est
vraisembablement avait rassuré beaucoup
plus l'électorat que les deux hommes
concourent à essayer quelque part de
capter vous réagissez sur le figaro.fr
sur twitter rose sur lefigaro.fr nous
dit je n'ai rien contre monsieur
philippe mais sa pédagogie sa
dialectique sont mauvaises
ce que confirme t jl ans est intéressant
puisque vous êtes plutôt majoritaire a
considéré qu' edouard philippe était
plus convaincant mais ce n'est pas
l'avis tjl qui nous dit philippe était
floue confus mal à l'aise
sur la question de l'immigration face à
invoquer direct et clair mais les points
de vue se rééquilibre un peu avec mon
singe qui fait remarquer que wauquiez
contrairement au premier ministre avait
besoin de notes et pour notre internaute
cela veut tout dire
olivier babeau il y avait des
propositions concrètes de wauquiez par
exemple il voulait supprimer l'aide
médicale
d'état qui permet aux immigrés en
situation irrégulière d'être soignés ou
bien de réduire le droit du sol
est-ce que sur le plan des propositions
vous l'avez trouvé convaincant alors
d'abord je veux pas trahir un secret
mais toutes les recherches en
psychologie cognitive montre que ce
genre de débat ne convainc personne ou
quasiment pas en fait on ne convaincre
les convaincus donc les gens qui étaient
d'un côté dire on a été très bien et les
autres de l'autre on dit très bien donc
voilà c'est très ragga vous avez une
toute petite minorité mais c'est
extrêmement marginale en réalité on a
tendance à plutôt penser que les
arguments de celui qu'on supporte a
priori sont plus convaincants que les
autres des luttes had d'exercice et de
tests scientifiques là dessus c'est
assez rigolo donc très concrètement ils
ont effectivement deux offres qui sont
relativement proches
et quand on fait du marketing politique
soyons un peu cynique parce qu'il a
abandonné c'est un petit peu ça plus
vous êtes proche en marketing plus vous
devez surjouée la différence évidemment
sûr que vous devez insister sur la
différence et il est absolument logique
que wauquiez chercher à l'amener sur le
point qui fait peut-être le plus
divulguer plus différenciant épique qui
fait actuellement qui fait plus mal
parce que c'est le point de faiblesse
aujourd'hui probablement de d'emmanuel
macron de façon générale sur l'économie
je pense qu'il est assez bardet et puis
c'est à difficile d'avoir une vraie un
vrai discours différenciant je vois pas
très bien d'ailleurs d'autres hubs
logistiques le nomine watts
sauf au contraire à prendre les gens à
contrepied parce que d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'on voit souvent dans l'opposition
aujourd'hui une position droite qui
réagit plutôt comme le ferait une
apparition de gauche en brouillant un
petit peu les signes parfois en faisant
des contre-propositions un peu
surprenante donc là on a très clairement
une position qui est extrêmement
différenciante et qui se sera je pense
c'est déjà les prémisses va probablement
être un des marqueurs de cette future
campagne européenne avec des
propositions venant plus ou moins
mon plaisir concrètes mais qui ont un
sens très clair c'est de dire si on a
beaucoup de migrants ou d'immigration
pas pourquoi on parle maintenant d'une
migration pas d'immigration qui a
abandonné ou s'il reste ça s'appelle de
l'immigration sais pas si c'est pour
insultante
il ya des gens qui immigrent peut-être
qu'on a tous immigrés un moment donné
effectivement s'il ya des gens qui
viennent et ben peut-être que le débat
c'est ce qu'il faut qu' il n'y ait pas
des quotas en fonction des compétences
par rapport à des compétences qui sont
demandés par l'économiste on décompte
attention par voter oui et dément et des
quotas en fonction de capacité
d'autonomie financière et de pourrait
dire de réfléchir au type d'incitation
qu'on peut offrir c'est le débat qui
veut qu'il veut porter je pense qu' il
n'y a pas tellement d'autres
propositions concrètes qui pourront être
apportées ça va être un débat tracer
clivant aujourd'hui que vous avez tué
une de ses propositions de laurent
wauquiez c'est de supprimer l'aide
médicale d'état
en dix ans il faut réserver le les soins
aux immigrés en situation irrégulière à
tout ce qui relève de la médecine
d'urgence
est ce que ça vous paraît abusif voilà
on répond ce qu'on répond d'habitude
c'est que les microbes ou les maladies
que dans ce reporter le l'immigrant se
moquent totalement n'ont pas de
passeport et se transmettent se
transmettront aux gens que côtoiera
c'est ce migrant dans les métros dans
l'est dans les rues dans les espaces
publics
donc c'est une proposition littéralement
stupide
on soigne les gens parce que ça permet
d'éviter à l'ensemble de la population
de tomber malade surtout ce qu'on peut
apporter des maladies tropicales enfin
c'est complètement crétin et c'est à
dire à 7 ce sujet de l'immigration et de
l'europe d'ailleurs parce que les deux
sont liés va probablement être le
marqueur principal des européennes
laurent wauquiez essayer de sortir de ce
piège peut-être dans lequel veut le
mettre le pouvoir consistant à dire
entre marine le pen et nous il ya
personne
oui mais laurent wauquiez il est sur ce
point là il a été quelque peu
désavoué par son camp politique puisque
la la figure au centre de cette
discussion c'est viktor orban qui fait
partie de la famille politique à
l'échelle européenne de laurent wauquiez
et laurent wauquiez soutien hors balais
servanac wauquiez soutien aux rebelles
mais il a été désavoué par ses
eurodéputés qui dans leur majorité ont
voté pour aller les sanctions
envers le premier ministre hongrois donc
il a essayé de sortir de cette ornière
là il a quand même un certain nombre de
problèmes à gérer sur cette question là
dans les mois à venir dans sa famille
politique
car la question de savoir ce que pensent
les républicains de victor banner dans
quel camp il se place elle reste entière
on ne sait pas exactement quelle
campagne va mener les républicains dans
alors que ses dents dans huit mois et
c'est un grand problème quand on va se
présenter devant les électeurs
donc elle les signaux sont au rouge pour
les républicains au dessus gérard
collomb le ministre de l'intérieur est
en visite aujourd'hui à grenoble
grenoble surnommé par les services de
police
la chicago française en raison de
l'importance qui a pris le trafic de
drogue jusque dans le centre-ville
cette visite intervient dans un contexte
sécurité assez assez lourd je le disais
au début d'émission
il ya eu hier l'assassinât du patron de
la police municipale de rodez
il ya aussi des scènes d'une grande
violence qui sont portées à la
connaissance du public ces derniers
temps regardez cette dernière vidéo on
la passera brièvement parce qu'elle est
tellement violente qu'on n'a pas envie
de faire de la publicité mais c'est une
scène qui se passe à garges-lès-gonesse
c'était mercredi soir dans le val d'oise
où un adolescent est très violemment
agressé dans une sorte de règlement de
comptes entre bandes
la police demande des effectifs
supplémentaires
elle n'est pas la seule d'ailleurs
écouter martine aubry la maire
socialiste de lille elle aussi trouve
qu'il n'ya pas assez de policiers
ayons plus de policiers nationaux et
aussi de crs non pas que je suis une fan
absolu des crs partout mais dans
certains cas je pense aux quatre tours
de lille sud qui sont tenus par des
dealers c'est pas pensable que dans une
ville il est des tours des assistantes
sociales des médecins puissent pu
rentrer ou les amis ou les parents
des familles qui habitent ne puisse plus
rentrer la glisse est plus possible on
n'est plus dans une république voilà
arnaud président et y est ce que ces
éléments qu'on a mis les uns côté les
autres parce qu'il survienne quasiment
le même jour en tout cas la même semaine
est ce que c'est le hasard ou est-ce
qu'on vous êtes un spécialité la
communication politique il ya une espèce
d'atmosphère en ce moment de 2,2
peut-être de d'insécurité alors il ya
plusieurs choses qui est vrai
aujourd'hui c'est que la sécurité est
déjà de plus en plus visible vous allez
montrer cette vidéo elle est extrêmement
intéressante est extrêmement violente
mais ça circule d'eau que au delà des
faits objectifs c'est-à-dire des faits
d'insécurité que l'on peut quantifier
statistiquement il ya aujourd'hui une
visibilité de la sécurité notamment à
travers les réseaux sociaux qui est
manifestement beaucoup plus forte
qu'elle ne l'était par le passé parce
que tout simplement on la voit en direct
ça c'est déjà une première chose donc ça
agit bien évidemment dans l'espace
politique dans l'espace public et ça a
un effet sur la façon dont les acteurs
politiques vont se positionner par
rapport à l'enjeu
le deuxième aspect c'est que
vraisemblablement aujourd'hui l'enjeu de
sécurité c'est un enjeu compliqué pour
le pouvoir parce que c'est un enjeu
compliqué parce que finalement
rappelez-vous au début quand emmanuel
macron à accéder à l'elysée on le
créditer d'une vraie compétence sur le
plan économique et par contre vrai sens
d'un déficit sur les questions
régaliennes et sur la question de
sécurité sur la question de la sécurité
donc aujourd'hui il s'agit pour lui de
et pour son gouvernement de montrer que
sur cette question qui est une question
qui indéniablement intéresse les
français
les indignes aussi il s'agit de montrer
qu'il est en mesure d'apporter des
réponses très concrètes à ce problème là
et manifestement il y à un troisième
problème c'est un troisième souci c'est
que la figure du ministre de l'intérieur
est une figure qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
forcément en mesure de porter cet argent
pour des tas de raisons parce que
distingue vraiment car il a dit qu'il
s'en allait
mais déjà l'historique l'historique déjà
de gérard collomb dans ce poste est un
peu compliqué mais en plus le fait qu'
il dise qu'il s'en va avec eux dans
quelques mois
il repartira à la conquête de la mairie
lyon n'arrangerait s'en rend pas la
situation
donc on voit bien que sur le plan là
aussi encore une fois la communication
politique du gouvernement sur l'enjeu de
la sécurité
c'est une question qui est extrêmement
difficile et auquel manifestement ils
ont quelques difficultés à répondre
alors on vous pose la question un mis
internautes avez vous l'impression que
l'état ne s'engage pas assez pour la
sécurité des citoyens et vous êtes 73% à
répondre oui donc à a regretté une
absence de d'engagement parce que c'est
un ressenti ou une réalité olivier
babeau ce qui a un sentiment
d'insécurité ou savez c'était lionel
jospin il n'ya pas d'insécurité il ya un
sentiment d'insécurité
ce qui est certain c'est que quand
l'état est fort et nous écrasent s'il
est faible nous périssons sais plus qui
a dit cette phrase c'est un libéral
d'ultra sans doute turbo libéral
aujourd'hui très clairement c'est pas
nouveau ça fait depuis très très
longtemps
l'action du ministre de l'intérieur plus
ou moins théâtral est toujours
cosmétiques rajouter deux trois
policiers c'est une façon peut-être de
traiter le symptôme mais traiter le
symptôme sait pas traiter la cause la
cause aujourd'hui c'est très très clair
c'est un délitement social dans certains
endroits lié probablement effectivement
communauté votre reportage à une absence
de mixité qui est extrêmement
problématique dans beaucoup d'endroits
et pour dire un sentiment peut-être
d'appartenance nationale qui est en
train d'exploser et qui donne ce genre
de pratiques violentes qui sont des
pratiques bas anomique on pourrait dire
de de rupture par rapport à la société
et de loi de la jungle
on n'a absolument pas aujourd'hui à
l'heure actuelle on est extrêmement loin
d'avoir les capacités
tu es landrier alors soit on devient un
état policier on arrive à peu près à
arrêter ça mais encore une fois c'est
que traiter le symptôme
soit on a une progression culturel
peut-être en termes comment dire
d'intégration nationale
mais ça c'est quelque chose qui prend 20
30 ans c'est aujourd'hui c'est une
situation qui y est le résultat d'un
poète les hlm dans lequel on peut pas
rentrer les endroits qui sont pris deux
heures en otage les quartiers où la
police va plus ça fait vingt trente ans
qu'on compte qu'on entend ça c'est pas
le changement d'un ministre ou son
sérieux c'est pas ça qui va changer
effectivement ce qui est un peu gênant
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a des images
beaucoup plus facilement cet effet de
visibilité il fait que peut-être que ce
sentiment d'insécurité la réalité elle
est toujours là je pense qu'elle grossit
mais ce sentiment lui va ne faire que
grossir poule alors ce sujet vous
intéresse beaucoup et vous êtes assez
précis dans vos remarques ioannou dit
martine aubry qui en appelle à la police
c'est cocasse quant à christophe il
revient sur cette situation très
dégradée à grenoble on nous disons les
sites et vivent du trafic de drogue
ces gènes ces jeunes pardon ne se
lèveront pas le matin pour travailler au
smic
guillaume houde il faut casser leur
business local et poursuivre les
acheteurs sinon ça va continuer beaucoup
de commentaires sur la situation à
grenoble notamment pour déplorer c'est
ce que fait aulas un peu la villeneuve
ce quartier qui était supposée être
innovant et qui en fait est un échec
puisque c'est là que se développent les
trafics boké et pat ce qu'ils nous
disent ce n'est pas un manque de
policiers
c'est un manque de réponse de notre
justice le étienne girard moi il ya une
image qui m'a frappé c'était il ya
quelques jours on a vu des agents du
samu du var présenter des gilets
pare-balles valorise et et blanc parce
que c'était des soignants est-ce que là
on est plus dans le sentiment la côte en
arrive là ça veut dire qu'il ya vraiment
un ans sauvagement de notre société
en tout cas et nous on fait notre une
dessus cette semaine ce qu'on constate
constatent empiriquement c'est qu'il ya
une montée en effet des incivilités des
comportements pas citoyens des insultes
face aux fonctionnaires quel qu'il soit
évidemment les fonctionnaires de police
sont en première ligne mais ça peut
concerner en effet les le personnel
hospitalier
les chauffeurs de bus ont comme vous
avez suivi cette affaire delà de la
claque de la gifle lancé par un
chauffeur de bus a même parlé d'un jeune
à un jeune qui l'insultait ça peut
concerner les médecins urgentistes
oui il ya un vrai constate d'urgence
justement à faire là dessus
le jour de l'état allait comment la
réponse de l'état allait jamais
suffisante
après si on regarde les chiffres on peut
constater que par exemple sur le budget
de la sécurité
le budget de la sécurité entre 2017 et
on a une hausse de 250 millions d'euros
on a eu 1800 recrutement de policiers et
gendarmes
pour autant ces policiers par exemple il
va falloir les former donc on n'a pas
immédiatement des forces supplémentaires
pour pour gérer la question
donc il n'ya pas de solution à attendre
immediate là dessus est ce que au niveau
des symboles est ce que est ce qu on y
est
est ce que l'état prend ses
responsabilités là aussi on peut penser
que non et notamment parce qu'on a un
ministre de l'intérieur et qui est quand
même le garant de la sécurité dans un
pays le premier flic de france qui
annonce qui va quitter son poste à l'as
vence et kinés et qui pourtant reste à
attendre et il n'est absolument pas il
n'est pas remplacé et il est absolument
pas inquiété alors que quand on quand on
dit qu'on part on sait très bien que
dans n'importe quel cadre
quand on est partant on perd un peu de
son autorité c'est là qu'on avait besoin
voilà je rappelle que effectivement
gérard collomb a déclaré qu'il
quitterait son poste juste après les
européennes c'est à dire en mai prochain
pour préparer les élections municipales
de 2020 puisqu'il sera candidat à lyon
georgia kuzmanovic jeu partagez vous
cette sévérité vis à vis de gérard
collomb widor collomb est en général du
traitement qui est fait à la police et
est la manière dont on traite la
sécurité dans ce pays parce qu'on est
quand même je les foule a que des des
gens du samu doivent doivent porter des
gilets pare balles ou que les pompiers
soient agressés dans des zones où des
petites mafias locales se sont arrogés
le droit d'avoir un contrôle total sur
de chasser l'état alors que quand on
chasse des pompiers et le samu
c'est qu'on veut marquer le territoire
c'est on est chez soi c'est vrai que il
ne sait surtout les des catégories
populaires qui n'ont pas accès à la
sécurité dont la république devrait que
la république devrait proposer à tous et
à tous ses enfants et je me souviens
qu'en 2012 lorsque nous faisions la
campagne présidentielle j'en ai
maintenant jean luc mélenchon nous
disions à l'époque déjà il manquait sept
mille policiers et quelques 8000
pompiers
depuis vous l'avais dit il ya eu un peu
de recrutements en 1800 mais on n'arrive
même pas à rattraper ce qui était déjà
en retard il y à il y a 6 ans on ad on a
donc d une police qui est en
sous-effectif qui en manque de moyens
mais là encore une fois elle n'est pas
la seule
l'école c'est la même chose l'hôpital
est ce la même chose les pompiers c'est
la même chose et ainsi de suite pour les
mêmes raisons parce que ce sont des gens
qui appliquent des politiques voulues
par l'union européenne de réduction des
dépenses publiques et donc ils
n'investissent pas là où il ya besoin
donc c'est un élément qui est important
et on fait du sparadrap
on met nos pauvres soldats qui font déjà
qui eux aussi sont en sous-effectif en
sauce ou moyens on les sort de leur
mission pour les mettre en sentinelle
c'est à dire plus de onze mille hommes
alors que arabes même un rapport
parlementaire fait par des députés de
droite et de gauche a montré que c'est
totalement inutile pour la lutte
antiterroriste à part attiré des
attaques sur sur nos militaires en
remplacement des rg qui ont été
supprimés hergé qui était extrêmement
utile pour ce genre de criminalité
et ne parlons pas de la fin de la police
de proximité de quartiers qui permettait
mais cela demande évidemment énormément
d'effectifs et dans le moyen et sané
mais besoin n'est pas mis en place
le souci c'est qu'on a des gens qui
actuellement sont au pouvoir et qui
applique
mais ce que vous voulez appliquer lénine
c'est le dépérissement de l'état et il
s'assure de faire dépérir l'état par
tous les moyens y compris par le côté
régaliens donc on attend
du l'orateur de la france insoumise
s'élever contre enfin plus exactement
regretté que la politique de lénine soit
mise en place
arnaud benedetti est ce qu'il ya encore
une fois tout est affaire de l'obesity
encore une il ya encore dans la
population française une demande
vis-à-vis des politiques où il ya une
forme de résignation sur ce sujet de
l'insécurité parce que les affaires de
violences à grenoble vous vous souvenez
de ces deux assassinats très violent et
rien n'a bougé
je suis pas sûr qu'il ya une
banalisation en tout cas par contre il
ya le centre une résignation
il ya peut-être le sentiment qu'il ya
une banalisation de ce type d'événements
de ce type de faits au niveau de la
puissance publique c'est à dire que
finalement les dirigeants
accepterez qui est un seuil
incompressible de violence ou
d'insécurité qui s'installe dans la
société
ce sentiment peut en effet quelque part
être générés par l'impuissance des
pouvoirs publics
à un moment donné à répondre aux
difficultés qu'on rencontre sur le
terrain ça je crois que c'est un fait
qui est important est l'enjeu
sécuritaire ils datent pas comme vous
l'avez rappelé il ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui
c'est un enjeu qui ne balaye la france
depuis près de 30 ans voire depuis 40
ans on avait des débats sur la question
de la sécurité sous françois mitterrand
on a eu des débats sur la sécurité sous
lionel jospin je rappelle que quand même
l'une des raisons de l'échec de lionel
jospin au saut au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle en 2002 c'est
aussi la question de la sécurité
donc ce n'est pas quelque chose qui est
forcément un nouveau aujourd'hui par
contre est ce qui est à mon sens réel
c'est que la perception de l'opinion
publique
c'est que finalement il y à une sorte de
résignation de la part de l'état à
laisser vraisemblablement des zones des
zones des zones de non-droit se
développer d'abord on se dit qu
évidemment ce genre de situation
c'est du pain béni pour marine le pen
oui parce que j'ai de plus en plus
l'impression alors moi qui suis
économiste quand même je me dis que ben
on n'arrivera pas parler d'économie
probablement aux prochaines élections il
est probable que l'on parle que d'autres
choses non c'est un peu dommage j'ai
l'impression que c'est quand même
important mais le fait est que on a
l'impression aujourd'hui une sorte de
balkanisation
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui les
gens qui ont les moyens finalement se
protègent de plus en plus migrent
migrent dans des zones plus favorisées
mettre leurs enfants dans les zones plus
favorisées dans les écoles ferment les
écoles plus favorisées donc
effectivement c'est quand même agréable
quand tu fais partie d'une certaine
élite et bat arrivent à échapper
le problème est la grande injustice et
que cette insécurité c'est qu'elle
touche d'abord et avant tout des gens
qui sont beaucoup plus modestes qui
bloque finalement l'ascenseur social
encore plus savez les archéologues
montre avec beaucoup d'intérêt par
exemple à l'époque mycénienne pas là
qu'on appelle l'époque palatial il y
avait des palais on est très surpris
parce que c'est pas les données
directement sur la campagne y avait pas
y avait pas de porte
y'avait pas de muraille est en fait un
moment donné se sont fait envahir et on
se rend compte que il y a des périodes
tout d'un coup on voit le niveau de
danger en fait au type de construction
qui n'a pas vu des squares ou s'élever
tout d'un coup des grilles des gens
fermer la rue où l'impasse dans
lesquelles ils vivent
on est en train de voir ça je constate
et dans beaucoup d'endroits aujourd'hui
on est une époque où on élève des airs
on élève des grilles et ça c'est
toujours mauvais signe parce que encore
une fois il espèce de balkanisation dont
les plus modestes
finalement sorte pourrait dire les les
plus enfin les moins préservé alors pour
les gens qui sont dans l'élite pendant
très très longtemps on peut
effectivement faire l'autruche et dire
qu'il se passe rien mais malheureusement
je pense pas que ce soit une question de
moyens je pense qu'on est depuis
longtemps beaucoup plus loin que ça
encore une fois il faut pas traiter le
symptôme c'est la cause et traiter la
cause ça prend des années on passe à un
autre sujet qui n'a rien à voir à qui
heureusement est un peu plus léger même
si le provoque aussi quelques tensions
le ministre de la transition écologique
et solidaire françois de rugy veut
réintroduire des nouveaux ours dans les
pyrénées
pourquoi et bien tout simplement parce
que il y en a pas assez écouté ce que
dit le ministre la principale
innovation c'est la même depuis de
nombreuses années c'est de permettre que
humilié une population d'ours durable et
viable dans le massif des pyrénées
puisque dans cette partie du pays armes
il n'y a plus que deux mâles donc l'idée
de réintroduire de femelle va permettre
de développer une petite population
d'ours localement ça s'inscrit plus
généralement dans une politique en
faveur de la biodiversité
alors donc le ministre a très envie
qu'ils aient davantage de l'ours dans
les pyrénées sauf que dans les pyrénées
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord
écouter ce que dit le maire de sarrance
cédant dans la vallée d'aspe dans les
pyrénées atlantiques il est directement
concernée par ce sujet et lui dit
arrêtez de nous mettre des nouveaux ours
c'est ce qu'on a fait dans l'ariège donc
plus à l'ouest des pyrénées et le
résultat c'est que les attaques contre
les troupeaux se sont multipliées écoute
l'arrière jour-là commencer par
introduire deux ours et on se retrouve
aujourd'hui avec carole tour en ariège
avec 400 attaques cette année en ariège
est on est on est on constate
aujourd'hui que l'état est dans
l'incapacité de gérer ce problème en
arrière georgia kuzmanovic vous êtes
plutôt ours ou plutôt du parti de l'ours
du parti du berger ouais je vais souvent
dans les pyrénées orientales et l'avait
déjà vu des ours papa pas en france hier
enfin d'autres pays sinon avant mais
messi en france dans l'est dans les eaux
malheureusement pas là n'est pas dans
les pires années puisqu'elles reviennent
mais vous avez des jours de l'ours dans
certains villages
ce sont des fêtes populaires qui renvoie
d'une vieille tradition locale
les gens se déguise en ours puis à
l'héberger pays chasseurs qui se met en
place
je dirai au maire que
il peut conserver sous un autre angle
d'abord l'angle écologique on a vu que
la réintroduction par exemple des loups
dans le wyoming a permis de remettre en
état y compris les rivières parce que la
chaîne la chaîne alimentaire
il ya un équilibre il ya un équilibre
dans la nature qui est rompu depuis très
longtemps par la sauvagerie de l'homme
qui a massacré tous les animaux en
particulier les grands animaux mais ça
peut être utilisé pour pour pour le
tourisme pour la diversité il ya
beaucoup de touristes qui viennent et
qui sont et qui sont touchés par par le
côté par le pastoralisme et ben voilà
c'est une manière de ce serait une
manière de faire et puis effectivement
il ya des attaques faut pas la foi ni
les des ours qui attaque qui attaquent
des des moutons mais je pense que le
principal problème pour sont frappés les
éleveurs ce sont les moutons qui
viennent à bas prix que ce soit du chili
ou de nouvelle-zélande où les prix
imposés par les grandes surfaces à
nouveau ses social peut trouver un
équilibre c'est à dire que si on si si
le tourisme valeur valorisé par la
présence des ours
et bien il y a des revenus qui en sont
tirés et ils peuvent servir à compenser
les bergers qui effectivement perdrait
risqueront de perdre bien évidemment
bien des moutons et à mieux les
indemniser on vous pose la question à
sur twitter êtes vous d'accord avec les
bergers qui s'opposent à la
réintroduction d'ours dans les pyrénées
non vous êtes plutôt pas d'accord à 61%
et il ya cet argument de pâtes kit qui
est frappé au coin du bon sens
semble-t-il
il nous dit les ours étaient là avant
les moutons denis est d'accord les ours
font partie du patrimoine français dans
ces régions et il faut absolument les
protéger étienne girard vous vous êtes
de quel dans quel camp bonjour je suis
pas un grand spécialiste de la question
de l'ours mais j'ai essayé de me
documenter n'est ce pas bon il faut
concilier ces deux impératifs
semble-t-il et c'est peut-être un peu ma
chronique et alors je suis un je suis un
chanteur at il poursuit
un vrai chantre du en même temps il
s'est semble-t-il possible
alors c'est quoi les enjeux il ya d'un
côté la biodiversité qui rencontreraient
une certaine identité culturelle dans
les pyrénées puisque ça a été rappelé
par le twittos seul ours étaient là
étaient là avant l'homme donc là il ya
quand même une logique à ce que ce qu'il
y ait des ours dans cette partie des
pyrénées l'autre côté l'autre impératif
c'est la liberté de commerce de ce
pauvre berger qui se fait manger ses
brebis ou tuer ses brebis par par les
ours
bon aujourd'hui reste que deux ours
mâles est-ce que inférées deux autres
femelles dans les pyrénées ça risque de
déstabiliser cet écosystème et à
empêcher le berger de vivre sans doute
pas mais la réponse ne serait peut-être
pas là même si on était trop d'ours dans
les pyrénées qui tuerait trop de trop de
brebis à ce que j'ai compris c'est 400
par an ça reste assez mineur 400 brebis
tuées par an à ces mineurs sur ce que
peut produire un berger dans les
pyrénées alors justement les bergers on
va en d'écouter un c'est olivier morin
il est l'heure un de leurs porte-paroles
donc tant les dans les pyrénées et lui
dit mais les vrais écologistes c'est
nous écoutez le face aux enjeux
environnementaux cruciaux que la france
a relevé françois de rugy n'a donne pas
d'autres priorités que de lâcher des
ours dans les pyrénées qui fait de
l'écologie au quotidien les ministres a
dit qu'un hélico voit l'avion ou c'est
nous qui la faisons l'écologie bergie
qui pratiquant l'agriculture 1 au bilan
carbone le plus vertueux de france
pourquoi ne s'attaquait pas aux gros
pollueurs et hong ran des ordres à
l'origine du dérèglement climatique
au lieu de distraire les foules avaient
des de l'ours médiatique
alors pour ceux qui n'ont pas suivi tout
ce dossier l'allusion aux ministres en
hélicoptère c'est parce que françois de
rugy est allé rencontrer des bergers qui
étaient favorables à la réintroduction
des ours
mais comme il était très mineur était
avec avait d'autres berger qui essayait
de bloquer les routes
monsieur derogy a pris son hélico
pour un bilan carbone probablement assez
mitigé arnaud benedetti est ce que vous
avez un point de vue sur ce sujet j'ai
pas de point de vue tranché certainement
moins en même temps que vous sur la
question mais par contre j'ai un point
de vue sur la communication c'est à dire
que cette problématique de la
réintroduction de l'ours
elle n'arrive pas de manière totalement
innocente elle arrive au moment où il y
un doute sur les engagements et la
sincérité de l'engagement écologique du
gouvernement donc il ya quand même un
contexte politique qui quelque part
accompagne la communication
gouvernementale sur sur le sujet je ne
suis pas sûr que ça soit la meilleure
manière que d'irriter les bergers de
l'ariège que de de promouvoir l'écologie
de la sorte avec eux cette mesure qui
est très symbolique que la
réintroduction de l'ours la défense de
la réintroduction de l'ours dans les
pyrénées il y a un petit côté quand même
même si les questions de biodiversité
sont absolument essentielle et
importante il ya aussi un petit côté
gadget dans cette affaire et je crois
que c'est quelque chose dont d'ailleurs
le représentant des bergers à a mis en
exergue dans son dans son discours
l'autre aspect moi ce qui m'intéresse en
tant que spécialiste de la communication
c'est pourquoi ça ne marche pas
finalement la communication on voit bien
que là on est dans une problématique
d'un communication absolue entre d'un
côté des gens qui sont sur le terrain
qui vivent leur métier avec les
difficultés qui sont les leurs et puis
quelque part une décision qui est prise
quand même de manière assez unilatérale
et d'une certaine façon assez
technocratique qui ne trouvent pas
l'assentiment des gens qui sont sur le
terrain
donc ça c'est ça qui est intéressant et
c'est très intéressant parce que
politiquement ça quelque part souligne
l'une des difficultés qu'a aussi le
pouvoir actuellement à un moment donné à
faire accepter à accepter les mesures
qu'il qu'il engage et en matière de
communication effectivement le ministre
qui descendent son hélicoptère avec sa
cravate et c&c richelieu noir c'est pas
l'idéal
ça vous fait rire
sur twitter christophe tout dit
heureusement que les écologistes ne sont
pas capables de réintroduire les
dinosaures tandis que jean-pierre nous
dit les berges et prennent des risques
pour leurs animaux et aussi pour olivier
babeau en fait cette histoire est
intéressante parce que c'est pas les
écologistes contre les pollueurs c'est
une écologie contre une autre écologie
celle de celle d'aider du des bergers
contre contre celle de la nature à
l'état brut
oui alors c'est vrai que si les
dinosaures étaient là avant et ça c'est
indéniable il va falloir les réintroduit
un de ces jours ci on peut effectivement
moi j'attends aussi que le camp vegan
viennent protester contre les ours
puisque de toute évidence ils tuent des
brebis
ça va bien j'attends qu'effectivement il
ya un moment donné ou oui c'est
peut-être que mons effectivement ça
paraît un petit peu gadget cette petite
affaire je pense qu'un équilibre à
trouver
je crois qu'il soit indemnisé il ya un
taux d'indemnisation sur la brebis tuées
bon bah je crois qu'on peut s'arranger
sur le coup peut-être même qu'ils
peuvent gagner de l'argent les braves
berger dont le métier est évidemment et
pas facile on a effectivement de deux
écologie en france il ya quand même ce
mythe écologique un petit peu difficile
aaa pourrait dire à combattre c'est
l'idée de plus en plus prégnante que
tout ce qui est naturel est forcément
bon la sig malheureusement c'est naturel
il ya plein de choses en nature qui
ressemblait pas bonne et finalement
lourd cette saison socrates en sait
quelque chose mais l'ours par exemple
bon bah il est bon il n'est pas il est
pas bon tout le temps partout il ya un
moment donné peut y avoir trop d'ours
peut-être qu'un jour ça pourrait me
poser les problèmes de sécurité pour les
gens parce que pour l'instant ces
problèmes pour la pour les moutons donc
ça va encore mais on pourrait imaginer
les problèmes de sécurité concrets à la
fois les louons c'est pas dangereux pour
l'homme contrairement à ce que beaucoup
pensent les sources ça peut être
beaucoup plus donc à un moment donné où
la nature infiniment bonne mais va
falloir quand même con que les hommes
décident de se faire une place
ou alors s'ils veulent réduire
complètement leurs empreintes on peut
effectivement une organisé une sorte de
vaste suicide collectif et la nature
pour à proliférer sans nous
merveilleusement ça a l'air d'être d'une
certaine façon
l'objectif un peu bizarre et paradoxale
d'un certain camp ultra écologique
puisqu'elle les ultra libéraux d'avoir
des ultras écologistes bon moment il
suffit de collectifs en train de faire
avec la surproduction sur la planète et
le changement climatique qu'elle induit
je pense plutôt que la réintroduction de
quelques pauvres
kiddo je vous l'apprends servent les
déjections servent à revitaliser les
forêts et parce qu'ils mangent tout
bêtement qui dans leur ventre sur la
notion des flics et non mais quand je
citais le wyoming le loup dans le
wyoming c'est que il ya des effets qui
sont connus qui sont pas juste du délire
des travées galvaudé ou des fanatiques
vert mais oui là vous avez raison c'est
que c'est surtout le représentant des
bergers c'est quand même la
communication du seul ministre qu'ils
ont trouvé qu'il verrait bien remplacer
nicolas hulot parce que toute façon il
n'ya pas de carrière politique à part
valait de marrons et et pour ce il doit
tout trahi il était une primaire et
s'est retrouvé en lui qu'on va pas donc
je pense que si si m'apprend n'entraîne
pas il a plus de l'apli carrière
politique
eh ben ils effectivement les abandonnent
sur tous les grands autres sujets comme
l'a dit comme l'a dit le berger
nous revenons à la couverture de
marianne qui nous a beaucoup inspiré
cette semaine bagdad après un sujet sur
les les violences contre les policiers
vous parlez aussi du dernier livre du
géographe christophe guilluy zl homme
qui avait inventé le concept de france
périphérique et qui cette fois nous
explique que partout en occident
les classes moyennes sont les grandes
perdantes de la mondialisation parce que
les très riches sont toujours plus
riches les très pauvres ceux des pays
moins développés sortent l'extrême
pauvreté
mais il ya forcément des perdants c'est
un peu ça là c'est un peu ça la thèse
tienne girard c'est ça et c'est la
vérification de la phrase de margaret
thatcher à la fin des années 80 qui nous
expliquer qu'il n'y a pas de société que
nous le titre du livre qui est très néo
society exactement la lutte des classes
ça n'existe pas et en effet elle a elle
a eu raison
c'est ce que démontre de façon assez
remarquable christophe guilluy on a sept
classes moyennes donc qui ne sait plus
vraiment si elle et des classes
populaires si elle est de la bourgeoisie
mais qui est un loup un grand magma
comme ça de gens passaient pour pour
toucher les aides sociales
pas assez riche pour toucher les niches
fiscales ou pour emporter leur
leurs revenus à l'étranger et qui qui
est cette classe sur lesquels on fait
peser sur laquelle on fait peser à
l'austérité
les baisses de budget etc
les les lignes les lignes de train qui
ferme c'est ces gens ces gens de la
périphérie qui voit là c'est un peu tout
ce peuple ce peuple là ces gens qui
habitent dans des dans des petites
villes où tous les commerces fermés qui
doivent aller faire leurs courses dans
les centres commerciaux de la métropole
à quelques à quelques kilos à quelques
dizaines de kilomètres de là et ce
peuple là justement ils votent de moins
en moins pour les pour les partis pour
les partis libéraux est de plus en plus
pour les partis populistes exactement
vous partager ce constat assez sombre
sur les classes moyennes qui serait en
fait les les sacrifiés de la
mondialisation
alors oui le constat est assez sombre
moi je n'accuserai pas le libéralisme
libéralisme il faut juste se souvenir
qu'il a permis à plus d'un milliard de
gens de sortir de la pauvreté
en réalité depuis 30 ans qu'en réalité
tout la prospérité qu'on a c'est parce
qu'on a la libre entreprise
la liberté le respect des droits
individuels tout ça c'est libéralisme et
le débat il est il est plus que ça c'est
qu'on est rentré dans une société post
industrielle et que cette rentrée un
société post industrielle elle se
caractérise effectivement par une
accélération de la progression des gens
qui sont en fait connecté à la
mondialisation qui pourrait dire en
profite formidablement à plein et puis
ceux qui sont déconnectés vont descendre
très rapidement et très vite et vous
avez effectivement une sorte de vide au
milieu donc on passe de plus en plus on
avait jusqu'à une société en losange
c'était la caractéristique des sociétés
développées si vous voulez en losange
c'est à dire qu'il y avait un peu de
gens au peu de gens en bas puis beaucoup
de gens au milieu et ça vous permettait
d'avoir une continuité et une
possibilité d'ascenseur social
aujourd'hui on passe de ce losange
problement une société en sablier qui
était la marque plus que la des sociétés
sous développés si vous voulez ou en
voie de développement comme on dit c'est
à dire où des dictatures c'est à dire
beaucoup de gens au beaucoup de gens en
bas et personne au milieu et peut sentir
ne sait rien sur l'aéroport c'est ce et
c'est très inquiétant parce que
nous en sommes en train de prendre la
voie que cas déjà prises états unis on
sait que donald trump a en grande partie
été élu par ses red necks delà de la
rust belt sinon pauvres les blancs
pauvres qui n'ont pas vu les avantages
de la mobilisation depuis 30 ans qu'ils
auront vu que leurs enfants ont perdu
toutes les perspectives et ne voit plus
de futur dans ce monde aujourd'hui
bah c'est aussi cet occident
vieillissant face à une plaque
asiatiques qui étant en plein boom qui
est en ralentissement économique
effectivement et qui crée ce 6e
diffraction qui est tout à fait clair à
tout à fait notable des internautes sont
assez sensibles à ce discours assez
critique qu'on nous a posé la question
selon vous le libéralisme détruite si
les classes moyennes vous êtes 60% à
nous répondre euh oui évidemment ce pas
un sondage puisque c'est vous qui
décidez si vous voulez vous exprimer ou
non de réaction celle de franz qui nous
dit le libéralisme associé à
l'individualisme et au consumérisme ont
détruit les classes moyennes christophe
nous dit ce sont les taxes et les impôts
qui tue les classes moyennes alors
kilométrique pense que c'est le
libéralisme non assumée à la française
qui tue je reprends son verbe les
classes moyennes arnaud benedetti ce
sujet est rarement traités en tant que
tels par les responsables politiques
sauf peut-être effectivement chez les
populaires et rarement traités en tant
que tels et pourtant on sait très bien
que les classes moyennes constitue une
figure absolue mon essentiel de la
démocratie il ya un philosophe et
oublier alain qui philosophe radical qui
expliquait qu' il n'y a pas de
démocratie radicale 102 radical social
ils ont radicalisé le de radical
socialiste pas au sens de radical comme
on l'entend aujourd'hui mais qui
expliquait de manière très explicite que
il n'y avait pas de démocratie s'il n'y
avait pas une sociologie des classes
moyennes et que finalement la démocratie
est indissociable du développement des
classes moyennes d'une société de masse
ou finalement des catégories fina
parviennent à avoir un niveau de vie et
d'éducation qui ont fondé citoyens et on
en fait aujourd'hui on est confronté à 7
à cette problématique qui est une
problématique de disparition progressive
des classes moyennes et de la même de la
conscience
à retenir à une classe moyenne une
conscience de classe qui permettait
aussi d'une certaine façon à la
démocratie de s'épanouir et sait déjà
qu'elle s'appauvrissent lc disparaissent
parce qu'elle s'appauvrissent mais
est-ce qu'elle s'appauvrissent du fait
de l'excès de libre échange parce que
c'est ça qu'on sent derrière le discours
qui est tenu dans cet ouvrage où est-ce
qu'elle s'appauvrissent aussi est un de
vos internautes la laf et l'a fait
remarquer du fait de l'excès de la
fiscalité parce que ça aussi c'était
c'est un vrai souci on a une fiscalité
qui en france est considéré comme une
fiscalité confiscatoire et qui le marque
traque aussi des classes moyennes donc
on a aussi un autre paramètre là qui
pourrait expliquer l'affaiblissement des
classes moyennes j'écoute ma navette je
pense que vous êtes d'accord évidemment
avec cette thèse de guy l'huile le
libéralisme fait du mal aux classes
moyennes mais bien évidemment qui fait
du mal aux classes moyennes mais c'est
vrai que le terme est mal posée je suis
d'accord avec monsieur libéralisme c'est
un concept philosophique très compliqué
on est tous attachés à l'état de droit
et la protection de la glande eu comme
c'est moi qui choisis le titre je
m'explique puisque n'allons pas clair
c'était libéralisme économique
alors on vient là donc c'est le
néolibéralisme l'ultralibéralisme
certains c'est tout ce qui est libre
échangisme et une idéologie
qui nous vient des états unis qui
pendant 30 ans a touché fortement les
classes moyennes dans un pays où l'état
encore été fort et là par la grâce à
l'impôt permettait d'avoir un état
providence très fort et devant des
policiers et des enseignants et des
hôpitaux et des soins pour tous et on a
un peu mis dans la tête des classes
moyennes qui vivait un statut un peu
supérieure l'idée que leur réussite
c'était surtout que c'était leur
combativité l'investissement au travail
ces tests et les thèses de yves montand
dans l'émission ya très longtemps et qui
s'appelait la crise quelle crise en 86
la crise vive la crise et il disait il
s'est terminé sur la crise quelle crise
bah c'était la crise du prolétariat des
ouvriers à ce moment là qui
effectivement était déjà touché les
premiers donc c'était les fermetures
d'usinés et grâce au libre échange et
d'ouverture des usines là bas et les
classes moyennes bon à ce moment là
c'est bon ça touche les touches de
prolétaires les ouvriers ils avaient
qu'à prendre le cheval de la modernité
mais maintenant c'est ultra libéralisme
atteint les classes les classes les
classes moyennes et de plein fouet et
c'est très intéressant parce que ça
ramène au premier sujet avec monsieur
wauquiez sur sur les migrations et c'est
très intense que lui non plus ne parle
jamais des travailleurs détachés
or l'union européenne a construit un
système où on peut jouer sur les
salaires et plus seulement des ouvriers
mais sur les salaires de toutes les
catégories socioprofessionnelles on peut
trouver des médecins absolument pas cher
en roumanie
et c'est légal des façons ce ne sont
même plus des migrants puisque tout à
organiser dans un élément dans ce marché
qui ne profite qu'aux plus puissants et
aux plus riches je vais terminer
et ce n'est bien sûr pas la fiscalité la
fiscalité confiscatoire
c'était roosevelt aux états unis ça vous
monte à 91% sur sur la marge la plus
haute la tranche la plus haute de
l'impôt sur le revenu or à ce moment là
c'est la peau qui permet à voir un état
fort qui permet une classe moyenne
d'exister il est temps qu est-ce qu on
que les classes moyennes se rendent
compte qu'il ne faut plus voter pour le
parti socialiste le rpr l'ump où les
républicains
car ce que ce sont des partis et les
conduisent à cette fable
il ya un grand danger pour qu'ils
passent contrat et on va voter les
français
non mais je viens juste un danger bien
juste un danger c'est quand les classes
moyennes se met dans l'histoire de dans
l'histoire de l'europe c'est quand les
classes moyennes se sentent déclassé et
se met à votre
et souvent les vôtres pour
l'extrême-droite et c'est ce qui s'est
passé il ya un seuil est un livre
célèbre d'un philosophe allemand qui
s'appelle pauvres petites sommes et ça a
mené au fascisme vert pour le muhr elle
djordjevic olivier babeau je voudrais
vous faire réagir à cette réflexion que
je trouve passionnante à l'internaute
dont le pseudo est isométrique le
libéralisme plus la fiscalité extrême
pour enrayer les effets du libéralisme
ça donne le cocktail français cet accord
avec sa wii alors parce qu'en france on
n'est pas en situation de libéralisme il
faut quand même le dire vu le niveau des
prélèvements obligatoires élus des
dépenses publiques ou quand vous savez
l'état dépense 4 chaque année en fait
ils empruntent un sur les quatre il n'a
vraiment que trois ans est déjà plus
évidemment les quasiment 100% de dette
publique dont on pas bon on n'est pas du
tout en état libéralisme ici on est au
contraire probablement dans une sorte
d'entre deux alors moi je n'ai pas du
tout envie d'aller vers le collectivisme
j'ai plutôt l'impression que les tailles
devra essayer de retrouver sa vraie
place et essayer de mieux faire
alors effectivement il ya en donner si
vous prenez tout aux gens ils ont du mal
à pouvoir joindre les deux bouts
quand quelqu'un touche 1500 euros en
pratique il touche 2000 2020 il coûte
2000 2500 euros c'est de l'argent qui
est des prix qui est dépensé par l'état
après il y avait les transferts sociaux
donc la réalité c'est que nous avons
effectué un problème de choix on est un
peu dans une sorte d'entre deux en
france et c'est probablement un de nos
problèmes
sachant que le problème il est mondial
aussi dire qu'on est dans une économie
où de plus en plus vous avez des emplois
très peu qualifiés d emploi moyennement
qualifiés qui sont en train de
disparaître rapidement grâce à la
robotisation et intelligence
artificielle ça c'est un vrai problème
disparition de saison pour la et puis
les emplois haut de gamme de créativité
avec dieu au maximum cette rue thiers
mais ce soir je vous coupe la parole ne
m'en veuillez pas merci beaucoup
point de vue reviendra lundi à même
heure même endroit
et d'ici là très bon week-end à tous
merci
[Musique]